Lincoln understood that he needed the
arts to replenish his soul everywhere
you look these days some painter
filmmaker and mime troupe seems to be
looking for a handout for the Arts the
hollywood-based creative coalition
recently descended on Washington to
lobby for increased funding to the arts
which helps explain why oscar-winning
actor Kevin Spacey was talking up honest
Abe's love of the theater
oddly he didn't mention that an actor
pulled the trigger on lightning but
despite all the star power in the
universe public funding of art is a bad
idea for at least three reasons last
December the Smithsonian's National
Portrait Gallery
almost immediately caved political
pressure and removed a four-minute video
called fire in my belly from an
exhibition on sexual orientation and
gender identity the gallery heads yanked
the piece which featured ants growing
over a crucifix after complaint from the
Catholic League and more important
several members of Congress who said the
piece was sacrilegious it's hard to
believe that a private museum would have
censored itself so quickly and so
craveable but when the taxpayer is
footing the bill the most easily
outraged constituent can wield a thug's
veto and who can blame them people don't
like to pay for things that insult their
most cherished values
government at every level is flat broke
federal state and local governments are
running massive deficits and shortfalls
and that's not gonna change anytime soon
proponents of the NEA and similar
programs say that arts funding amounts
to just pennies per citizen while b-2
bombers costs as billions but it's all
money we don't have and just because
defense spending is out of control and
needs to be cut drastically is no
argument for funding yet another season
of dr. Hoover erupts
during a recent congressional hearing
the head of the National Endowment for
the Arts defended tax funding of the San
Francisco mime troupe on the grounds
that it was a world-renowned theater
organization that makes important
contributions to the American theater in
other words it should have little and no
problem generating philanthropic
donations from theater lovers all over
the globe apart from taxes Americans
give about thirteen billion dollars in
philanthropic donations to the Arts
every year that's a lot of money and if
it's not enough to cover every request
well then the San Francisco mime troupe
will just have to do better at working
the craft for reason TV I'm Nick
Gillespie
you